i think the pm's are the national health
service is the pride of our whole united
kingdom
and all the more so after it has been
there for us during the worst pandemic
in a century
treating almost half a million patients
administering more than 88 million
vaccines and saving countless lives
but the inevitable consequence of this
necessary and extraordinary action
is that kovid has placed massive
pressures on our nhs
as we stayed at home to protect the nhs
thousands of people did not come forward
for the treatment they needed
like those who suffer from kovid these
are all people we know your aunt who
needs a new hip your neighbor who has
problems with their heart and needs a
pacemaker your friends your friend at
works who thinks that they should get
that lump or cough checked out
so we must now help the nhs to recover
to be able to provide this much needed
care to our constituents and the people
we love and we must provide the funding
to do so now
we not only have to pay for the
operations and treatments that people
decided not to have during the pandemic
we need to pay good wages for the 50 000
nurses who will enable that treatment
and who can help us tackle waiting lists
that could otherwise expand to 13
million over the next few years
we need to now to go beyond the record
funding we have already provided and we
need to go further than the 48 hospitals
and 50 million more gp appointments that
are already in our plan
so today we are beginning the biggest
catch-up program in nhs history tackling
the covid backlogs by increasing
hospital capacity to 110
and enabling 9 million more appointments
scans and operations
as a result while waiting with willis
will get worse before they get better
the nhs will aim to be treating around
30 percent more elective patients by
2024 2025 than before coving
and we will also fix the long-term pro
problems of health and social care
of health and social care that the party
opposite certainly failed to attack on
mr speaker
and that have been so cruelly and that
have been so cruelly exposed by kovid
but having spent 407 billion pounds or
more to support lives and livelihoods
throughout the pandemic from furlough to
vaccines it would be wrong for me to say
that we can pay for this recovery
without taking the difficult but
responsible decisions about how we
finance it
as a permanent additional investment in
health and social care it would be
irresponsible to meet the costs from
higher borrowing and higher debt
from next april we will create a new uk
wide 1.25
health and social care levy on earned
income hypothecated in law
to health and social care with dividend
rates increasing by the same amount
this will raise almost 36 billion pounds
over the next three years
with money from the levy going directly
to health and social care across the
whole of our united kingdom
this won't be pay for pay awards for
middle management it will go straight to
the front line at a time when we need to
get more out of our health and social
care system than ever before
and it will enable radical innovation to
improve the speed and quality of care
including better screening equipment to
diagnose serious diseases such as cancer
more quickly designated surgical
facilities so non-urgent patients are no
longer competing with a e
faster gp access to specialists so you
don't have to wait months to see someone
in hospital to find out whether
something is wrong
and new digital technology so doctors
can monitor patients remotely in their
homes and we will do all this in a way
that is right and reasonable and fair
mr speaker some will ask why we don't
increase income tax or capital gains tax
instead but income tax isn't paid by
businesses so the whole burden would
fall on individuals roughly doubling the
amount that the basic taxpayer could
expect to pay and the total revenue mr
speaker from capital gains tax amounts
to less than 9 billion pounds this year
instead
our new levy will share the cost between
individuals and businesses
and everyone will contribute according
to their means including those above
state patient per pension age
so those who earn more
those who earn more will pay more
and because we are also increasing
dividends tax rate we will be asking
better off business owners and investors
to make a fair contribution to
in fact
the highest earning 14 percent will pay
around half the revenues no one earning
less than 9
568 pounds will pay a penny and the
majority of small businesses will be
protected with 40
of all businesses paying nothing at all
and while scotland wales and northern
ireland have their own system we will
direct money raised through the levy to
their health and social care services so
in total scotland well yes in total
scotland wales and northern ireland will
benefit from an extra 2.2 billion pounds
a year mr speaker
and as this as this is about 15 more
than they will contribute
through the levy it will create a union
dividend worth 300 million pounds mr
speaker
worth 300 million pounds
but mr speaker we can't just put more
money in
we need reform and change
we need to build back better from covid
when the koben storm broke
last year
there were 30 000 hospital beds in
england occupied by people who could
have been better cared for elsewhere and
who wanted to be better cared elsewhere
that's 30 000 mr speaker out of 100 000
hospital beds in our nhs costing
billions every night and unable to be
used by people needing cancer care
needing hip operations making it harder
than ever to deal with the growing
backlog in our nhs
too often people were in hospital beds
because they or their relatives were
worried about the cost of care in a
residential home
and that same fear kept many others at
home without any care at all this
anxiety
affects millions of people up and down
the country the fear that a condition
like dementia one of nature's bolts from
the blue could lead to the total
liquidation of their assets
their lifetime savings
their home the loss of everything that
they might otherwise pass on to their
children however great or small
while sufferers from other diseases who
have been
have to be in hospital for the majority
of their treatment have their care paid
for in full
by the nhs
governments
have ducked this problem
for decades
parliament
parliament even voted to fix it
and
yet that 30 000 figure
is an indictment of the failure to do so
and so mr speaker there can be no more
diver and delay we know we can't rely
solely
we know we can't rely solely on private
insurance because demand would be too
low for insurers to offer an affordable
price
and a universal system of free care for
all
would be needlessly expensive when those
who can afford to contribute to their
care should do so
instead the state should target its help
of protecting people against the
catastrophic fear of losing everything
to pay for the cost of their care and
that is what this government will do we
are setting a limit
on what people can be asked to pay
and we will be working with the
financial services industry to innovate
and help people to insure themselves
against expenditure up to that limit
wherever you live
whatever your age your income or your
condition
from october 2023
no one starting care will pay more than
eighty six thousand pounds over their
lifetime and no one with assets less
than twenty thousand no one with assets
less than twenty thousand will have to
make any contribution from their savings
or housing wealth that's up from
fourteen thousand pounds today
meanwhile anyone with assets between
twenty thousand and a hundred thousand
pounds will be eligible for some
means-tested support
and this new upper capital limit of a
hundred thousand pounds is more than
four times the current limit helping
many more people with modest assets
and as we fix this long-term
long-standing problem in social care
we will also address the fears that many
have about how their loved ones will be
looked after by investing in the quality
of care in carers themselves and by
integrating health and care in england
so older people
and disabled people are cared for better
with dignity
and in the right setting
and my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for health and social
care will be bringing forward a white
paper on integration later this year
mr speaker you can't fix
you can't fix the covid backlogs without
giving the nhs the money it needs
and you can't fix
the nhs without fixing social care you
can't fix
social care
without removing the fear
of losing everything to pay for social
care
and you can't fix health and social care
without long-term reform the plan that
this government is sending out today the
plan i'm setting out today will fix all
of those problems together and of course
and of course
no conservative government no
conservative government speaker ever
wants to raise taxes and i will be
honest with the house i accept yes i
accept that this breaks a manifesto
commitment which is not something
which is not something i do likely but a
global pandemic was in no one's
manifesto mr speaker
and i think the people of this country
understand that in their bones and they
can see the enormous steps this
government and the treasury have state
have taken and all these after all the
extraordinary actions that have been
taken to protect lives and livelihoods
over the last 18 months this is the
right the reasonable and the fair
approach enabling our amazing nhs to
come back strongly from the crisis
tackling the covid backlogs funding our
nurses making sure people get the care
and treatment they need in the right
place at the right time and ending a
chronic and unfair anxiety for millions
of people and their families up and down
this country and i commend this
statement to the house